- Well now it's time for
tonight's Hashtag Wars.
Moshe Kasher.
- Non-Racist buckwheat
- Points.
(laughing)
April.
- Unfrozen caveman gynecologist
- Points.
(laughing)
Moshe.
- Debbie Down Syndrome.
(laughing)
- Points.
Jerry.
- John Wayne Gacy's World
- Points
Jerry.
- Mr. Bill Cosby
- Points.
Oh no.
Moshe.
- The Coneheads but
they're actual cone heads
due to a con genitive birth defect.
- Yes, points.
April.
- Two wild and crazy gays.
- Points, yeah.
Moshe.
- Hans and Frans Nazi war criminals.
- Points.
Moshe.
- Asian-American cast member.
- Rob Huebel.
- Grand Theft Auto Vice Kitty
- Yes, points.
Keegan.
- Super Meow-io Brothers.
- Points.
Paul Scheer.
- Kitty Crush.
- Yes, points.
Rob Huebel.
- Dead Angry Birds.
- Yes, points.
Paul Scheer.
- Grand Theft Cat-o: Kitty City.
- Oh, fine, points.
- Yeah, it's so cute.
- Keegan.
- Halo Kitty.
- Yes, points.
Rob.
- Call of who doodied in my litter box?
- Okay, points.
Hopefully it was the cat.
Rob again.
- Assasin's Creed: All Dogs Must Die.
- Points.
Keegan.
- Allergic the Gathering.
- Yes, points.
(laughing)
Points, Paul Scheer.
- A light mist of cat urine.
- Ron
- You were a bar and
grill, I was Toby Keith.
- Points.
Pete.
- You were the female
star of Transformers,
I was the visionary director
that put that camera in your toilet.
- Okay, points.
Could be anybody.
Ron.
- You were a watermelon I cut a hole into,
I was lonely Gallagher.
(laughing)
- That's so specific.
- I'm going to crush
you in a different way.
- I've never broken one from the inside.
Points to Ron Funches.
Pete.
- You were the cop tasering me,
I was the guy who can't get
hard unless someone tases me.
- Points, yeah.
Steve.
- You were the one with the sad eyes,
I was the one that could
see your true colors.
- Yeah, aww.
Oh, the crowd not behind you Steve.
- Not behind me on that one.
- No points, I'm sorry.
Steve, though, again.
- Yes, you were the masseuse
that wouldn't give the hand job
and I'm the guy screaming,
"But I'm John Travolta."
- Yeah, points.
- Got it back, got it back.
- Pete Holmes.
Again, could have been anybody.
Could have been anybody.
Pete.
- You were the adorable
black comedian on @Midnight,
I'm standing right next to you.
- Aww, missed connection
is no longer missed.
Ron Funches.
- You were great television ratings,
I was the Pete Holmes show.
(laughing)
- Dana Gould.
- Pretty Boy Ellen.
- Yes, points.
Nick.
- Buffalo Bill Cosby.
- Yes, points.
(laughter)
Dana Gould.
- Ted Cinna-Bundy.
- Yes, points.
Nick Offerman.
- Jesse James the motorcycle douchebag.
- Points.
(laughter)
Dana.
- Butch Cassidy and Jerry's Kids.
- Points.
(laughter)
Aimee.
- Doc Holiday Inn.
- Yes, points.
Nick.
- Jon Wilkes kissing booth.
- Yes, points.
Aimee.
- Weird Al Capone.
- Yes.
(laughter)